so hi everybody my name is al I'm a data
scientist in lab genius a biotech
company and I'll talk about optimizing
for multiple objectives and with
application to protein design so
optimization means different things to
different people so I'll be talking
about the procedure of finding and
comparing feasible solutions until no
better solution is found where the
emphasis is where you have two spaces of
interest one is the decision spec
decision space where you have fully
controlled full control over the
parameters and they're mapped to the
object to an objective space so in our
context the decision space would be like
DNA sequences and that would be mapped
to like protein functionality
now most real life problems involve more
than one objective normally in conflict
you can imagine for example quality
versus price or in the knapsack problem
you want to maximize the value of the
packages that you pack in as opposed to
the weights and so you can imagine that
you do not want to analyze for this
linearly because if you optimize for one
you degrade the other so you want to
treat this you want to treat this
optimization simultaneously hence multi
objective optimization now you all know
that that you're going to have to make
at some stage a subjective decision so
the question is when are you going to do
this for example a lot of people what
they do is they combine the different
objectives into one new objective and
ultimately they do single objective
optimization just imagine giving weights
like quality / price that would be a new
objective for the purpose of this talk
I'm more interested in making that
decision explore exploring the full
potential of the search space and
leaving that decision for the end or
ordering the optimization so this is
this is an example of an of an objective
space here on the right so you have two
objectives and these are these these are
solutions that are possible and how do
you find which is the optimal solution
well you have what's called the Pareto
front and what that means is you have a
set of equally optimal solutions each
with its own trade-off
after you are exhaust exploring the
space then you sit with the X domain
expert and you decide which trade off
are you willing to give up you got to
the other that means that the waiting
process you uh you saved for the end as
opposed to if you would do it in the
beginning you would be limiting yourself
to a very narrow search space that's
what you're effectively doing and you
can imagine doing this in multiple
dimensions not only to objectives and
another nice aspect is that it this when
you're applying this you do not care
about like you you don't have to scale
in advance or you don't have to worry
about units of measure imagine comparing
dollars versus kilograms in the now in
the knapsack problem so you're agnostic
to that and deal with it only afterwards
so if you can brute force your way all
the way to the purpura the front great
you're done but most likely if you're
like us you're dealing with a highly
complex space and you want to use a
stochastic optimizer we like to use
evolutionary algorithms for the reason
that they nicely they're first of all is
simple to implement and second they're
very useful for solving for conflicting
objectives so this is a shout-out to the
developers of the Python platform called
deep which provides evolutionary
algorithms as addition to a Pareto front
algorithms MapReduce and they really
make prototyping for multi objective
optimization very simple this is a
example snippet of code of mine where
the platform for the platform I just
have to provide these functions of of
crossover mutation evaluation and the
the the selection tournament and it does
all the rest so just before I show case
studies just some context so I work at
lab genius we're a biotech company where
we put data at the center of everything
that we do our superstar biologists they
engineer proteins in in the laboratory
our objective is discovering useful
therapeutic drugs and what they'll do is
they'll provide me with data the data
that they provide me is sequence DNA
sequences that are scored according to
the objectives that were interested in
optimizing anything between stability to
manufacture ability and then I'll apply
multi objective optimization so here
I'll just show this is a first frame of
an animation here I'm showing two
objectives fitness versus something that
we call similarity each dot here is a
result of a protein library what that
means it's an aggregate of could be
millions of sequences and so just before
I run the animation just to define the
pareto front our objective is to get
over here and so in this first iteration
this is the pareto front and while I run
the optimizer you'll see it's suggesting
libraries meaning dots that are closer
to this Pareto front and the front
itself will move towards the X so you
can imagine doing this with more
objectives in in more dimensions but you
can see here in two dimensions like it
converges and then I will sit with all
set with the biologist and we'll figure
out which library words which libraries
were interested in actually creating in
the lab and further iterating and
improving the drugs that we're exploring
this is similar to before with with a
different data here the objective is to
get to the top right here's focusing on
this objective called Fitness
and what's what's cool over here is just
showing the evolution in process I'll
just rewind this to the beginning this
is the original library we're pretty
liberal at which base pairs were
interested in at the beginning and then
we're letting the optimizer do its thing
we have a model that links between the
DNA and the protein functionality here
called Fitness and it finds its way to
rule out base pairs that aren't useful
as opposed to ones that we should be
preparing in the lab so you probably
you'll probably go home and wonder
should I apply multi objective
optimization to my line of work so two
key features that you want to ask do you
have more than one objective that are
potentially conflicting and it when it
comes to decision space do you have full
control over the parameters so if
anybody's interested or has experience
I'll be in a pub I'll be glad to talk
about this or anything else a few
resources I find useful is anything that
a car's Itzler writes I wrote about this
this is his PhD he makes it really clear
again the developers of deep created a
great platform for quick prototyping and
just a community announcement we are
looking for an experience data engineer
if you yourself or you know anybody in
your network is looking for an
opportunity a great company that's
really looking to push the envelope in
discovering of therapeutic drugs then
please make connection so thank you
[Applause]